[Música]
muy buenas noches y bienvenidos a este
especial informativo en france 24
dedicado a la convención nacional
republicana que hoy entra en su tercera
y penúltima jornada en las próximas dos
horas y media vamos a llevarles toda la
información y el análisis de lo que
ocurra en esta celebración que por
motivos de la pandemia de kobe 19 se
realiza de manera virtual estaremos
dialogando con nuestras corresponsales
en washington y nueva york así como con
distintos invitados que nos ayudarán a
entender y analizar los discursos que se
pronuncian durante esta noche desde los
estados unidos para empezar vamos a ver
quiénes son los oradores más destacados
de esta tercera jornada de la convención
republicana por supuesto que esperamos
que hable el vicepresidente de eeuu mike
pence que aceptará su nominación para
renovar su cargo como coequipero de
donald trump por otros cuatro años en
caso de resultar reelectos penn se
dirigirá de manera remota a la nación
desde baltimore se espera un discurso
cargado de símbolos patrios y por
supuesto estaremos pendientes de lo que
diga con respecto a la pandemia de ccoo
y 19 pues fue él el encargado de liderar
la fuerza de tarea
responder al brote que ya deja más de
175 mil muertos en el país ahora también
su esposa karen pensó en lo que se
espera sea un discurso basado en la
importancia de la fe y con el que hará
un llamado a movilizar el voto femenino
en los suburbios estadounidenses se
espera que también hable por su parte
lara trump esposa del hijo del
presidente trump el trump vemos que ha
estado siempre presente la familia del
presidente en esta convención
republicana y también esperamos que se
dirijan a nación y que elián conway una
de las masas es de las más viles
asesoras del mandatario y que
recientemente anunció que se retira de
la casa blanca para dedicarle más tiempo
a su familia
pues esta es la tercera jornada de la
convención republicana en eeuu por
supuesto nos acercamos al final mañana
en la última jornada de este evento que
se realiza de manera virtual debido al
coi 19 y empezamos hablando con ma
mensah la corresponsal de france 24 en
la ciudad de nueva york quien nos va a
ofrecer un panorama de lo que podremos
ver esta noche en esta convención
republicana mamen bienvenida una noche
más usted ha estado pendiente de la
reconvención demócrata la semana pasada
y ahora la republicana cuéntenos desde
lo que usted ha visto durante las dos
primeras jornadas de esta convención que
podemos esperar para esta noche
sin muy buenas noches desde nueva york
pues va a ser una jornada interesante en
la que a pesar del mensaje positivo que
los republicanos intentan mostrar y que
sobre todo interesa mucho a donald trump
al presidente no le va a quedar más
remedio que enfrentarse a la situación
actual y es que pues estarán al tanto de
todo lo que está ocurriendo en este país
como decías continúan aumentando los
casos de coronavirus hay a 58 millones
de infectados y más de 179 mil
fallecidos los incendios en california
con miles de desalojos
el huracán laura que se acerca a la
pandemia y por supuesto las violentas
protestas que hemos visto en wisconsin a
raíz de ese ataque a un joven
afroamericano así que el presidente don
al tram no le va a quedar más remedio
esta noche que empezar a hacer frente a
esta realidad que estamos viviendo vamos
a ver personajes importantes dentro del
partido como decía su mano derecha el
vicepresidente maipés que hablara de
economía y de política exterior y además
va a defender la actuación por parte de
la casa blanca ante esta pandemia
interesante también y una persona que se
ha añadido a la agenda en el último
momento
el tío de la empresa cuya recordarán
esta polémica que hubo sobre la defensa
que hizo este señor de la actuación de
donald trump que dio lugar a que se
proclamará un boicot contra sus
productos a través de las redes sociales
pues bien esta noche lo vamos a poder
escuchar también escucharemos a dos
afroamericanos que defenderán un poco
unas protestas pacíficas pueden ser
posibles y apoyarán también esa idea del
presidente de donald trump de ley y
orden veremos también una activista por
los derechos civiles y bueno va a ser
una noche muy emocionante en la que no
nos podemos lamentar un momento una cosa
durante sobre admisión va a mena
interrumpo porque habla en este momento
la secretaria de prensa de la casa
blanca una de las primeras en dirigir
uno de los de los discursos esperados en
esta jornada vamos a escucharla desde
este momento
amigos en mi familia
diagnosticados con cáncer de seno y
varias en sus tempranos 20 60 ahora me
encuentro el mismo me encuentro con el
mismo prospecto por una década que ayer
estuve en un centro de cáncer haciéndome
ultrasonidos y toda la vigilancia que se
necesita durante estas visitas web en
paro y me encontré con muchas mujeres
luchando contra el cáncer y luchando con
la quimioterapia eran un testimonio para
la fortaleza de eeuu
ellos son los héroes de eeuu el primero
de mayo del 2018 seguí los pasos de mi
madre
eligiendo tener una doble mastectomía
preventivas tuve miedo de que me preparé
para perder un pedazo de mí misma por
siempre pero el día siguiente con mi
madre mi padre mi esposo jaime
jesucristo a mi lado
eliminando el cáncer de seno de una
decisión que ahora celebró la
reconstrucción del seno avanzado
increíble aunque ha sido una decisión
difícil mi doctor y yo
william james tomamos una decisión que
me dijo virtualmente sin cambios estaba
pero con jane cambios físicos instará
increíbles desarrolle confianza en mí
misma
james durante estos tiempos difíciles y
dejar de su forma y espero tener el
apoyo de mi familia fuerte nine eo pero
tuve más apoyo del que esperaba
una de las primeras llamadas que tuve
fue de ivanka trump aldair caber
mientras me recuperaba en mi teléfono
volvió a sonar era el presidente trocha
llamando para saber cómo estaba hoy
estaba sorprendida mirá acá estaba el
líder mainz y preocupándose por mi
situación en el momento sólo había
conocido el presiente trump en algunas
ocasiones pero ahora lo conozco muy bien
y les puedo decir que este presidente se
extinguen
defiende a los estadounidenses
estadounidenses con condiciones
preexistentes esto pretende hecho esta
mañana hablé con el presidente trono y
me dijo que estaba muy orgulloso de mí
por compartir esta historia en la misma
forma en que el presidente me apoyó él
los apoyó a ustedes lo veo todos los
días hay gente se lo escucha decir que
la parte más difícil de su trabajo es
escribir a las personas que han perdido
algún familiar soldados
reding erentxun basterds son grande
visto como se acerca a los padres que
han perdido a algún hijo en el crimen en
las calles oa las personas que han
perdido sus trabajos y media que
presidente lucha por los estadounidenses
porque a él le importan las historias
como ésta hay manto de harén tengo una
hija de 9 meses fue sweet brother ella
es una niña dulce increíble y elija
didn't trabajar para este presidente por
ella misma cuando miro a los
de una nueva vida con un milagro
en el cuello tengo una responsabilidad y
que debo proteger mi expresión significa
proteger el futuro de eeuu
un futuro del presidente trump para
luchar donde nuestros vecinos están
protegidos donde la vida es sagrada
un lugar donde dios es atesorado no se
saca de nuestras escuelas terroristas
mari borrado de nuestra historia
quiero que mi hija
james emerja en el estados unidos del
presidente donald trump
escoger hacerme una masectomía quien ha
sido la decisión más difícil que he
tenido que hacer para que purguen quiero
apoyar al presidente trump jacques maite
va a proteger a mi hija ya nuestros y el
futuro de nuestros hijos esta fue la más
fácil
[Música]
pues escuchábamos la intervención de que
el imac nani que es la jefe de prensa de
la casa blanca ella hacía un recuento de
una situación de salud por la que tuvo
que pasar y mostró como el presidente de
trump la ha estado respaldando vamos a
ver en este momento con nuestra a bueno
vamos a hablar en este momento vamos a
escuchar ahora a cannes venecia la
segunda dama de nación y a la esposa del
vicepresidente mike pence antes de
volver con nuestras corresponsales
escuchemos lo que dice entonces la
segunda dama de eeuu esposa de mike
pence como nuestras hijas
charlotte gran rey y las futuras
generaciones se van a poder ser
escuchadas y sus votos van a contarlo
buen mensaje las mujeres pues de que el
sufrimiento
womenheart opportunities church y para
lograr france telecom el significante
mens grandes logros en tanto a nivel
civil como en el gobierno
esta noche vemos a héroes en nuestra
tierra
viena 16 de pastrana harriers
no he tenido el honor de conocer
bastantes héroes a través de todo este
país
gm los pins son una familia militar
nuestro hijo pertenece a los marines y
nuestro hijo herbie pertenece a la
armada muchos es una de nuestras
iniciativas estrés pausas calentar a las
esposas de los militares así como
nuestra hija y nuestra nueva rival son
héroes también heroína seguir showman
historia de san jose escuchado muchas
historias en q de voluntariado y de
grandes contribuciones a las fuerzas
armadas en nuestras comunidades mis
pasos las esposas de los militares hacen
grandes movimientos cambian este trabajo
ejercen de madres solteros mientras
exhiben orgullo fuerza y determinación
y de ser parte de algo mucho más grande
que ellas mismas a todas las esposas de
los militares
el presidente trump y el vicepresidente
penis han apoyado las fuerzas armadas de
eeuu incluyendo las familias en una
escala significativa
mientras viajaban a nivel general del
país adoptando políticas
para gas en norte respaldó simplemente
para permitir el empleo de esposas
militares en liza brasil y cameron cruz
estas esposas del ejército decidieron
empezar un negocio llamado ciber robots
de la segunda guerra mundial hacen unas
bolsas increíbles diseñados por las
esposas de militares y muchas de estas
esposas viven a nivel nacional y ellos
preparan su sección de la bolsa y le
envían
el estado de carolina del norte donde se
ensambla el producto final
johnson en montana
es una artista culinaria que ha soñado
con crear su restaurante
empezó su restaurante
así que si abrió un segundo restaurante
hámster y como la segunda dama
la terapia para los veteranos
es bastante efectiva para el estrés
postraumático
el general cristo un veterano que conocí
en tampa bay en el que estuvo en irak y
en afganistán y dijo que nada lo había
apoyado más después de haber estado en
los marlins hasta que logró y aceptó ir
a la a tomar esta terapia y pues sea
terapia de artà
salvo su matrimonio y su vida sus crisis
siguió para establecer un lugar para
ayudar a otros veteranos men y mandaron
en muchos de nuestros héroes veteranos
luchan mientras hace su transición hasta
la vida civil y en algunas ocasiones el
estrés es muy difícil para manejar solos
hace unas semanas tuve el honor de
hablar con algunos estadounidenses
increíbles paisas wine que respondieron
a la línea de
veteranos en crisis sin dean morgan me
contó una historia que me impactó
ceniza eres signis no me dijo que ha
sido el honor más grande de su vida
hasta que físicamente llegan a una
clínica para recibir la ayuda que
necesitan y pueden ayudarlos a los que
necesitan en estos tiempos difíciles
todos vemos tantos ejemplos de todos los
estadounidenses diariamente que ayudan a
quienes los necesitan aquellos martins
en humildad han considerado a otros más
importantes que a ellos mismos que hemos
visto los trabajadores de la salud
profesores
las personas en primera línea
los oficiales las personas que trabajan
en alimentos agricultores y tantos otros
héroes todos
hace 100 años que las mujeres aseguraron
su voto
así que votemos poner o no haremos a
nuestra historia votemos al reciente
trump y el vicepresente pence por 34
años
dios bendiga a nuestros héroes y dios
bendiga a estados unidos
pues escuchamos las palabras de karen
pensé ya es la segunda dama de eeuu
justamente por ser la esposa de mike
pence quien busca junto al presidente de
trump la reelección como su llave
vicepresidencia y he resaltado un tema
que es de hecho el tema de la jornada y
es la tierra de héroes ese ha sido el
eslogan preparado por el partido
republicano para la jornada de hoy
tercera y penúltima de la convención
republicana
escuchamos ahora aquel jan con walt una
de las principales asesoras del
presidente del trono durante varios años
quien recientemente anunció su renuncia
para dedicarse a la familia importante
escuchar el testimonio de que janko
world
no sólo para el presidente trump sino
por décadas él ha elevado a mujeres a
posiciones altas tanto en los negocios
como en el gobierno y él confía en
nosotros respeta nuestra opinión e
insiste en que nosotros estamos
equiparados a nivel de los hombres el
presidente entró
text me ayudó a romper una barrera en la
política dándome el poder para manejar
su campaña de manera exitosa con la
ayuda de millones de estadounidenses
nuestro equipo se desafió a los críticos
en güigüe y ganamos femenía das win para
muchos de nosotros
el empoderamiento femenino no es un
eslogan no viene de los medios sociales
viene de todos y las heroínas que nos
criaron y que creyeron en nosotros sus
ventajas yo fui criada en una casa donde
todos eran mujeres
enrique o bien te airlines sus vidas no
fueron fáciles pero nunca se quejaron
manifestar el dinero era poco pero
teníamos abundancia lo que más
importante la familia fe y libertad ail
donde yo aprendí que en eeuu
ned flanders y greens de promesa de la
promesa de eeuu nos pertenece a todos
esta es una tierra de inventores
innovadores de emprendedores y
educadores de pioneros y padres que brin
cada uno contribuyendo al éxito y el
futuro de una gran nación y de su pueblo
dice everyday hills sabe también en
president camps de twitter y profesora
que tomó tiempo extra para ayudar a sus
estudiantes para que se acomodaran de
manera virtual las enfermeras que
terminaban un turno de 12 horas sólo
tomaban un tiempo corto sólo para
cambiar sus guantes y mascarillas para
volver a empezar
ya los emprendedores abrieron su negocio
es una vez más luego de la pandemia y de
la del caos
a quienes finalmente después de 10 años
tienen un seguro social
trinian's reciente trump ya el
vicepresidente defensa han dado dignidad
y resultados a eeuu he visto de primera
mano muchas veces fairing el presidente
confortando ya ayudando a un niño que ha
perdido a un padre a un padre que ha
perdido a un niño a un trabajador que
perdió su trabajo
a un adolescente
que perdió su camino en las drogas les
ha dicho no pierdan la esperanza
asegurándoles que no están solos y que
ellos importan de weiss ellos siempre
van a ser personas
y nuestra responsabilidad es enfocarnos
en aquellos que tienen menos que
nosotros
el presidente de trump a eso
precisamente eso el action tomar
acciones sin precedentes para combatir
la crisis de drogas en este país me ha
dicho que esto es tan importante que ya
no se tantas vidas han sido renovadas
por la adicción y nosotros ni siquiera
lo sabemos porque la gente le da
vergüenza a pedir ayuda y no saben a
quién pedir ayuda en sus peores momentos
en vez de mirar para el otro lado el
presidente del pse es miro a la crisis
de la droga directamente y creando una
legislación para asegurar la inversión
en seguridad en educación en prevención
tratamiento y recuperación en la uer y
tenemos un gran camino por recorrer
pero la el silence el estigma y el
estigma que previene a la gente de pedir
ayuda se está desvaneciendo
y este es el hombre que conozco y el
presidente que necesitamos por otros
cuatro años más
él toma las luchas más difíciles
y combate él me ha apoyado y él los va a
apoyar a ustedes de weening en honor de
las mujeres que me empoderaron aquí por
el futuro de los niños que todos
queremos gracias y dios los bendiga
siempre
pues eran las palabras de william conway
ella es una de las principales asesoras
del presidente de donald trump quien
recientemente anunció que se va a
dedicar a su familia que se retira por
ahora de la casa blanca vemos como han
sido por ahora protagonistas las mujeres
enviando un mensaje muy importante
hablando sobre los jóvenes sobre los
héroes sobre las mujeres que están
justamente conmemorando el derecho al
voto los 100 años del derecho al voto en
eeuu en esta jornada vamos a volver por
un momento con nuestra corresponsal en
nueva yor ellas mamen sala con quien
hablábamos al inicio esta transmisión
especial en france 24 am en regresamos
con usted como podemos resumir esos
primeros momentos de la convención
republicana
estamos viendo mujeres principalmente
hablarle a la ciudadanía estadounidense
todavía no se habla de tema co y todavía
no se habla de tema de manifestaciones
contra el racismo se está apelando más
al voto femenino y al voto de los
jóvenes usted como lo puede interpretar
desde nueva york
y luego este va a ser otro de los temas
durante la jornada de hoy la defensa de
la importancia de la mujer y lo hemos
visto en estas tres últimas oradoras
interesante también como ha mostrado esa
parte que no habíamos visto hasta ahora
en las anteriores jornadas que es
mostrar la empatía que el presidente de
donald trump tiene y cómo ha cuidado de
su equipo en este tiempo que han estado
trabajando con ellos algo que se acerca
más a la fórmula que vimos en la
convención demócrata y que casan menos
con la actuación que hemos visto hasta
ahora de la parte republicana mucho más
fuerte en sus discursos mucho más
atacantes para atacante y desde luego
esta tercera jornada está siendo mucho
más tranquila en ese sentido luego
también es interesante ver cómo están
contando historias personales que hasta
ahora habíamos escuchado menos por parte
del equipo de donald trump a lo largo de
la noche escucharemos también el
testimonio decíamos anteriormente de
activistas por los derechos de los
derechos civiles y de afroamericanos
también para hablar de este tema que
decía es precisamente de estas revueltas
que están ocurriendo en wisconsin
más allá de eso decir también pues bueno
los temas que han defendido cómo es esa
empatía por las mujeres de los militares
de los veteranos que en este país tienen
pues mucho peso y que donald trump
quiere por supuesto contar con todo su
apoyo pues mamen es que hemos justamente
el desarrollo de el eslogan del título
de la jornada tierra de héroes vemos
cómo se han resaltado ese tipo de roles
y también podemos pensar una respuesta a
las palabras de joe biden quien ha dicho
que el presidente tram sólo piensa en sí
mismo y que no se va a levantar cambiará
pensando en la población estadounidense
tal vez estamos viendo la reacción a eso
y vamos a darle justamente con diana
castañeda nuestra corresponsal en la
ciudad de washington capital de estados
unidos junto a la casa blanca está ella
con la información y ccoo de análisis
diana bienvenida a esta especial
informativo al igual que mamen usted ha
estado acompañando la jornada de la
convención republicana esta es la
tercera y también la de la semana pasada
con la convención demócrata como podemos
pensar que se está dibujando la noche de
hoy vemos mujeres sobre todo en los
diferentes momentos de los diálogos de
los de los testimonios que estamos
viendo
que sale el tema de la empatía pero
también la realidad del país hoy es que
está la pandemia de koi 19 pues
repuntando como ha sido siempre desde el
inicio la pandemia y que están las
protestas en que no sea también ardiendo
y con víctimas fatales por primera vez
bienvenida a este especial lesbiana
así es lo que hemos visto durante esta
convención republicana es como el
partido ha reforzado esta narrativa de
proteger y defender a las fuerzas
policiales en toda la nación y también
veíamos como por ejemplo la convención
demócrata había una gran diferencia
frente a la reforma policial que estaba
anunciando el partido demócrata para que
aquellos policías que se vean envueltos
en hechos en donde termine víctimas
sobre todo pertenecientes a minorías
como parte de estos encuentros pues se
puedan aumentar la cantidad de jueces y
los recursos para que estos policías
sean juzgados lo que estamos viendo
ahora es una narrativa completamente
diferente y durante toda esta noche en
la convención republicana vamos a tener
en muchos miembros de las fuerzas
militares dando su testimonio y también
dando esa parte de patriotismo
a esta transmisión que se hace de manera
virtual pero lo que también veremos
durante esta noche que hemos visto
durante los pasados días esta semana es
ese discurso que tiene el partido
republicano de reforzar la idea de que
si tú aún no es elegido no es reelegido
y llega a la casa blanca en 2021
entonces básicamente estará en peligro
la nación debido al socialismo demócrata
como lo han venido calificando y también
reiterando un poco el tema principal de
que los medios de comunicación
significan una amenaza por la
desinformación que brindan y veíamos
precisamente a que habían conway quién
es una de las principales asesoras de la
casa blanca que también estaba encargada
de esta estrategia para el manejo de los
medios de comunicación hablando y se
espera igualmente que veamos esa misma
línea por parte de los miembros de la
familia del presidente de donald trump
oí hablar a una de las esposas de uno de
sus hijos quien también es asesora de la
casa blanca
diana pues justamente hemos visto
durante estas dos primeras jornadas de
la convención republicana participación
muy activa de la familia trump ayer
escuchábamos el discurso de melania
trump la primera dama la nación
escuchamos ya también a varios de sus
hijos e hijas también participar en esta
convención republicana por el momento de
dar paso a los invitados porque hay
análisis también aquí en france24 y
vamos a presentarles en este momento a
los invitados que hemos convocado para
este análisis estamos hablando de jose
bastos politólogo analista político y
periodista que se conecta con nosotros
desde washington dice también tenemos a
jeffrey quien abogado analista político
consejero en liderazgo hispano que
también se encuentra en washington dice
y finalmente jesús garza economista
autor en finanzas y magister en economía
por la universidad de essex de reino
unido- bienvenidos a france 24 y este
análisis especial informativo sobre la
convención republicana en su tercera y
penúltima jornada y quiero con ustedes
analizar estos discursos que hemos
estado escuchando hasta hoy y un poco
también de lo que ha sido la convención
y sus jornadas anteriores para llegar ya
a lo que sería de pronto
jornada de mañana con unas luces más
caras de lo que podamos ver entonces
vamos a hablar con jeffrey quien es
abogado analista político y vamos a
preguntarle cómo ve hasta ahora que se
viene dibujando esta idea de la de la
tierra de los héroes vemos ya tres
discursos importantes entre ellos el de
la segunda dama de eeuu que menciona
reiterativamente como los de cómo los
militares han estado trabajando por el
país como las esposas de ellos también
han estado resistiendo en diferentes
momentos difíciles de la nación usted
como como percibe esta puesta en escena
la tercera jornada la convención
republicana también desde su desde su
nombre la tierra de los héroes
sí
bueno no tenemos entonces por ahora el
audio de jeffrey quien igual estamos
realizando con el equipo técnico de
france 24 este este tema del sonido pero
vamos a hablar con jose bastos
politólogo desde washington dice jose
confirme si usted me está escuchando
bien y también le transfiero la pregunta
cómo podemos analizar el hecho de que
hoy la prioridad del partido republicano
sea mostrar la empatía donald trump con
la gente estadounidense con los héroes
con los médicos los soldados los
militares y sus esposas usted como lo
percibe hasta este momento de la tercera
jornada la convención
sí sí sin duda un cambio con relación a
lo que veníamos observando y lo que
viene siendo la campaña en general de la
reelección de trump que ha sido sobre
todo un mensaje de miedo de lo que
podría hacer eeuu
si yo va a ir en gana no creo que es
algo digamos importante dar ese mensaje
de mostrar a un donald trump digamos
compasivo que tiene mucha empatía con la
gente me sorprende un poco que lo hagan
personas que trabajan con él y que no lo
hicieran en días anteriores sus hijos no
y sus familiares es un poco más
directamente también es algo que
sorprende que no se vea mucho de donald
trump en el día a día no porque en el
tema del cob y por ejemplo con 170.000
muertos es muy poco lo hemos visto a él
directamente dirigirse a los familiares
de las víctimas dirigirse a las personas
que han perdido sus negocios por ejemplo
y sin embargo escuchamos a sus asesores
decir él siempre nos muestra de sant
para ti a uno uno pensaría que desde la
presidencia pueden mostrar mucho más esa
empatía directamente a las familias que
han perdido sus seres queridos no eso no
se ha visto y realmente desde el punto
de vista bueno de campañas políticas
una oportunidad perdida obviamente más
allá de la vela de la tragedia que
significa en la realidad no hemos visto
en muchos países del mundo que
presidentes han ganado popularidad
precisamente por mostrarse al frente de
la situación mostrarse muy empáticos eso
no se ha visto con donald trump en eeuu
por eso sorprende un poco escucharlo en
estos discursos pues agradecemos a jose
bastos pero vamos a continuar y arreola
a seguir ahora con el presidente de la
asociación nacional de organizaciones
policiales mal
mcmichael mccain que está hablando
justamente en este momento vamos a
escucharlo y ahora vemos con nuestros
invitados juntos que atacan a nuestros
oficiales de policía
legislación al apoyo para autorizar
fondos para apoyar a primeras personas
de la línea del 9/11 y sus familias
policiales han jurado
a ir al peligro cuando todo el mundo
huye lo hacen con deseo para proteger a
nuestras familias ya nuestras
comunidades
estoy orgulloso que la mayoría de los
oficiales policiales son los mejores de
los mejores y arriesgan sus vidas sin
dudarlo
los policías saben
que nos apoyamos así que
desafortunadamente creo que los
resultados cuando no se dan como en
portland minneapolis chicago y nueva
york
hacen la decisión consciente de no
apoyar a los rings oficiales asesinatos
tiroteos la violencia y la sangre
derramada que se ven en estas ciudades
no está ayudando ahora es una suerte es
un resultado para mi deber no permitir
que los oficiales protejan a nuestra
comunidad eso
como senador kamala harris
apoyó restringir a la policía contraste
cortar su entrenamiento
y hacer que nuestras comunidades y
vecindarios sean más peligrosos que ya
son de lo que ya lo son el presidente
trump apoya la creación
un lugar de entrenamiento nacional para
desde escalar y comunicar para darle a
los oficiales más herramientas para
resolver conflictos sin violencia
la diferencia entre trump pensé y bailén
harris
es clara con sus opciones
weaver
como la más propicia les o las más anti
radicales valoramos la seguridad de
nuestros familiares para unirse a los
miembros de la asociación de
organizaciones policiales y apoyar la
reelección del presidente de donald
trump
gracias
y dios bendiga a estados unidos
[Música]
escuchábamos a michael mackail de la
asociación nacional de policía y
presidente de su organización y por
supuesto marcando un tema que es
trascendental para la jornada y para las
elecciones presidenciales de eeuu el
próximo 3 de noviembre y es el tema de
la seguridad por supuesto que este año
ha estado marcado por las propuestas de
reforma al accionar de la policía y
mencionaba justamente el que kamala
harris y joe biden dupla a la
presidencia por el partido demócrata
está apoyando esas reformas a la policía
por supuesto desatada hasta la muerte
del afroamericano georg floyd el pasado
25 de mayo aclare ese tema ahora sí con
jeffrey quien abogado desde washington
quien estaba a punto de conectarse
contra el 24 para hablar de estos
discursos señor quién cuénteme usted qué
opina de este de este discurso en el que
por supuesto se pone sobre la mesa el
hecho de que el partido demócrata
representado por giovanni kamala harris
esté a favor de transformar de reforma
del accionar policial y que por supuesto
el presidente la organización de policía
de eeuu no esté de acuerdo con esto
estamos ya hablando del tema de
seguridad que se le vende a la
ciudadanía como de los puntos clave
lección a la seguridad de los eeuu es un
tema fundamental y clave los que han los
que han visitado estados unidos saben
que acá la policía es muy eficiente acá
puedes ir a la tienda y te regresas con
las bolsas en la calle no te va a pasar
nada las casas no tienen rejas las
puertas no tienen rejas vives tranquilo
ya qué se debe eso se debe a que la
policía es muy eficiente y si cumple su
trabajo lo que han lo que están haciendo
los políticos del partido demócrata es
desfinanciar la policía ya lo han dicho
hay avisos por todo eeuu e inclusive en
washington donde la alcaldesa es
demócrata donde dice que le van a quitar
el financiamiento al cuerpo de policía
en qué resultado esto nueva york- el
número de tiroteos se ha disparado 300
por ciento ni hablar en chicago donde
han habido 300 muertos simplemente
porque los políticos le están quitando
el apoyo el apoyo a la policía y esas
dos son ciudades de demócratas
demócratas entonces hay que tener mucho
cuidado de lo que están diciendo
de este discurso político de que vamos a
desfinanciar a la policía de que vamos a
corregir la policía no les no les va a
favorecer a los candidatos del partido
demócrata yo te lo digo porque conversó
en la calle dice no como es posible no
yo necesito más policía en mi barrio
porque el los criminales están saliendo
a robar y mucho más ahora que estamos en
medio de una pandemia y menos dinero y
están saliendo a robar ahora el partido
demócrata apoya abiertamente a estos dos
movimientos radicales posiblemente
terroristas que es black lives mother y
antifaz que se han dedicado a atacar a
la población civil a destruir negocios
de inmigrantes pequeños negocios van y
los destruyen o como sucedió el día de
ayer a que en washington dc los los
restaurantes han empezado a abrir los
restaurantes mayormente contratan
inmigrantes hispanos
una turba
de chicos de blacklight madre entraron a
restaurant a gritarles a los comensales
no diciéndoles oye tú eres un racista
simplemente porque estás sentado acá y
yo quiero que levantes el puño y digas
que eres un eres eres un racista tal
cual sucedía y algo y suceden en estos
momentos en algunos países comunistas y
de verdad te digo que esto no lo vamos a
permitir aquí no lo vamos a permitir
aquí en eeuu es una tierra de héroes y
los héroes somos los civiles que nos
tenemos que defender bueno si vamos es
un tema por supuesto neurálgico de este
especial informativo de las 24 y de las
elecciones como ya lo decíamos en eeuu y
que otras darles también la pregunta a
jesús garza economista quienes se
conecta ha comprado 24 también haremos
de este tema tema seguridad justamente
como lo decía jeffrey quien es nuestro
invitado que acaba de darnos su opinión
pues el presidente ahora alto hoy mismo
refiriéndose a todas las manifestaciones
que se están presentando en wisconsin
también se refería a enviar
a los diferentes efectivos de la fuerza
pública a la ley el orden a mantener el
orden por supuesto y evitar también los
desmanes y los saqueos usted qué opina
de la de esta de esta postura del
partido republicano sobre mantener el
ejercicio policial como diciendo hasta
ahora
es una aclaración yo soy profesor
delegada de business school aquí en
monterrey con mucho gusto yo creo que si
hay un tema de fondo racial en estados
unidos y ya lleva muchos muchos años en
ese sentido creo que el uso de la fuerza
es excesiva en estos momentos
como ya se ha visto las protestas es la
sociedad civil y creo que deberían de
tomar medidas más inteligentes para
tratar de calmar la situación de
seguridad en los eeuu no es la primera
vez que sucede de hecho los últimos 34
meses hemos visto un escalamiento de
agresiones de la policía hacia la
sociedad civil
entonces yo sí considero que es
exagerada el uso el exagerado uso de la
fuerza pública en este sentido en la
población recordemos que también está el
problema del cobismo es una situación
difícil para la población
entonces sí creo que es excesiva el uso
de la fuerza en estos momentos en los
eeuu
bueno quiero trasladar esta pregunta que
es muy importante durante esta jornada
muchas gracias a los invitados que ya
dieron su opinión a jose bastos con
quien habríamos esta ronda de más
seguridad por supuesto que también
veíamos la jornada hoy llamada tierra de
héroes tema seguridad cuando aunque no
sea en eeuu se vivirá tercer una cuarta
jornada ya de manifestaciones para la
clase
valeo a jake blake por parte de un
policía blanco de eeuu y cuando vuelven
también estas manifestaciones a las
calles cuando por primera vez tenemos
dos víctimas fatales heridas de bala en
estas manifestaciones es el tema
seguridad neurálgico los republicanos
plantean mantener la policía o incluso
reforzarla a los demócratas plantean
transformarla o quitarles ciertos en
ciertos privilegios llamémoslo esta
forma sobre la sociedad civil usted qué
opina de la forma como este tema va a
influir en las diferentes posturas de
los dos partidos
sí creo que sin duda el tema de
coronavirus seguirá siendo el
determinante de aquí a noviembre el tema
de la seguridad de la policía y de las
tensiones raciales se ha hecho
obviamente muy importante desde mayo
sobre todo como mencionaban con con el
caso de georg floyd y ciertamente
algunos desmanes algunos saqueos que han
habido en los últimos meses que indica
todo indica que eso está favoreciendo al
presidente de un autónomo no la gente en
las encuestas indican que hay una
mayoría de la población que si quiere
reformas policiales que si rechaza este
uso excesivo de la fuerza que obviamente
critica lo que pasó con georges lloyd l
la muerte de una persona desarmada a
manos de la policía pero no no parece
que haya un apoyo de la población a una
reforma tan profunda oa retirar parte
del presupuesto no como se ha mencionado
creo que también hay que aclarar que joe
biden y su campaña no han dicho que
estaban de acuerdo con retirar fondos de
la policía ha dicho que están de acuerdo
con reformas si hay grupos y
congresistas demócratas
radical o más de izquierda que yo vaivén
que si hablan de default police no voy a
retirar los fondos a la policía y
quitarle digamos la importancia que
tiene la policía en muchas ciudades
muchos como yo bailé y también muchos
alcaldes muchos gobernadores han
rechazado como tal es el lema porque
consideran que bueno pues tiene que
haber reformas pero que quitarle el
presupuesto puede ser más bien peligroso
pero en cualquier caso sin duda ha sido
un tema importante los republicanos
saben que a pesar del apoyo de la gente
a las propuestas pacíficas
hay un rechazo amplio a este tipo de
saqueos y acciones como la que
mencionaban en este restaurante en
washington y sí creo que hay un balance
digamos muy muy tenso no cuando la
protesta se exceden pareciera más bien
favorecer a los republicanos y este
discurso de la ley el orden que tanto de
lo que tanto habla donald trump claro
pero también cuando la policía es la que
se excede parecida a eso favorecer a el
grupo demócrata porque definitivamente
pues hemos visto que han sido reales las
muertes de esas personas pero quiero
hablar ahora con ustedes de un segundo
tema que ha sido por supuesto
determinante durante esta campaña y es
el tema
19 ya lo mencionaba josé bastos en su
intervención y es que eeuu tiene 175 mil
muertos la cifra está por s por ese
rango y siguen continúa siguen
aumentando los casos y los contagios
también las hospitalizaciones y las
muertes quiero empezar entonces hablando
de nuevo con jeffrey quieren que nos
cuente un poco como el partido demócrata
pues ha expresado en diferentes
oportunidades la falta de acción del
presidente tomó lo que ellos consideran
falta acción del presidente de tron
frente a la crisis del coi 19 y en
cambio la convención república en el
tema kobe no ha sido protagonista no se
ha hablado casi que ninguna de las tres
jornadas sobre este tema es muy poco y
esperamos que vice presidente mike pence
en su discurso hoy pueda darnos unas
luces sobre esta estrategia usted qué
opina
tenemos que volver a la normalidad la
civilización ha pasado ha pasado por
muchas pandemias las hemos superado y
hemos vuelto a la normalidad y nosotros
también tenemos que volver a la
normalidad mucho más en esta situación
de que es muy sospechosa de lo que
estamos viviendo con este virus que vino
de china de un país que es comunista
pero te quiero hacer una aclaración
sobre el crecimiento de los números de
casos que lo escucho en la prensa global
en la enfermedad dura entre máximo 15
días es una persona sana entonces
después de los 15 días una persona que
dio positivo al cob en haití pnh tiene
que ser sacada de ese número y eso es lo
que la prensa no está haciendo ustedes
continúan sumando sumando sumando
sumando sumando pero hay que sacar a las
personas que ya han pasado los 15 días y
han creado los anticuerpos y quizás no
necesitan ni siquiera una vacuna ahora
cómo ha reaccionado el presidente de
donald trump frente a la pandemia te
quiero decir algo en dos semanas eeuu se
puso a producir los famosos respiradores
mecánicos y se logró juntar en almacenes
hasta 100.000 respiradores mecánicos en
eeuu cualquier persona que ha necesitado
hospitalización ha tenido una cama
disponible y toda persona que ha
necesitado un respirador mecánico lo ha
tenido disponible la capacidad médica la
capacidad hospitalaria era tan grande
tan grande por la reacción que tuvo el
gobierno federal que se ha quedado vacía
hay muchos en muchos lugares se ha
tenido que desmantelar hospitales que
habían sido armados en york no sé si tú
recuerdas en el medio de la pandemia en
el estado de new york se envió un
hospital dentro de un barco y se
construyeron varios hospitales y esa
capacidad no se logró no se llegó a
utilizar al nueva york le fue muy mal
porque ellos establecieron una
cuarentena demasiado rígida si tú
analizas lo que está pasando alrededor
del mundo los países que han que están
imponiendo una cuarentena salvaje una
cuarentena rígida les está yendo muy mal
eso fue lo que sucedió en el estado de
nueva york y en el estado universe y
ambos estados gobernados por demócratas
y lo que hizo el gobernador como que se
dedica solamente a insultar ya criticar
a trump de contagiados con kobe k
ancianos con contagiados con joven los
volvió a regresar a los a sus asilos
sus lugares de reposo y ahí fue cuando
se desató una en una catástrofe murieron
once mil personas dentro de los de los
lugares de reposo de ancianos y eso no
es culpa del gobierno federal eso es
culpa de como y de di blasio por favor
la prensa tiene que decirlo por favor
digan lo es o ha sido manejo netamente
dentro del estado de nueva york es
demócrata y ahora tú me dices 170 mil
víctimas bueno eeuu tiene de acuerdo al
censo 330 millones de habitantes quizás
seamos más a 370 tienes que medir la
fatalidad de acuerdo al millón y eso es
bajísimo acá y el 98 por ciento de los
fallecidos son personas grandes 76 años
para arriba y yo tengo las encuestas yo
trabajo con ese señor es justamente la
cifra de eeuu como usted lo dice que
tenerla en cuenta igual que con las
demás naciones del mundo respecto a la
la cantidad de población nacional pero
de todas formas eeuu está en el lugar
número uno del mundo
tanto en contagios como en cuanto a los
muertos así que independientemente pues
la nación está en el primer lugar en ese
aspecto y más allá analizar las cifras
de kobe 19 es cómo está siendo éste un
punto neurálgico en la campaña
presidencial en eeuu que ver sobre esto
con el jesús garza jesús garza que como
nos aclaraba es el profesor de economía
y finanzas del business school cuéntanos
cómo se está enfrentando este tema del
coi 19 la convención republicana porque
hasta ahora parece de gran ausente no
hemos visto todavía a ninguno de los
speakers hablando de como el presidente
truman realmente ha podido aprovechar o
no o cómo puede hacer frente o no a esta
crisis del coi 19 se habla de otros
temas pero este ha sido un tema que nos
falta por discutir la convención usted
cómo lo ve
claro yo yo creo que se hizo un mal
trabajo o sea como tú mencionas las
estadísticas no mienten en europa las
tasas de mortalidad son mucho más bajas
y yo le atribuyo mucho al sistema de
salud en europa mientras que todo el
mundo está cubierto el sistema de salud
universal en eeuu más difícil y también
con personas más vulnerables por ejemplo
los inmigrantes no tienen acceso como
cuantos países europeos pero me gustaría
tocar el tema que tú mencionas
relacionado con la economía claramente
trump él ha vendido mucho el auge
económico el crecimiento económico el
bajo desempleo que sí ha experimentado
los eeuu en estos momentos y por eso la
retórica desde el inicio de abrir la
economía lo antes posible recordemos que
durante los meses de abril mayo y junio
que probar sobre el mayo cuando pegó más
la pandemia eeuu sufrió un desempleo muy
fuerte de tasa desocupación muy alta
inclusive hasta tres veces más que sus
padres en europa y esto fue por y
quisiera enfatizar esto los apoyos
fiscales mientras que en el reino unido
o alemania por ejemplo los apoyos fueron
dirigidos para proteger a los empleos
el 80 de hecho en el reino unido- el 80
por ciento de los apoyos iban directos a
pagar nómina para no crear desempleo en
eeuu se hicieron apoyos directos y eso
genera un desempleo fuerte ahora lo
importante es a partir de mayo eeuu se
empieza a abrir de hecho en muchos
políticos que empiezan
ya no darle importancia al confinamiento
por el por el hecho de la economía y los
otros meses mayor junio y julio la
economía americana parece que ya se está
recuperando a costa de estos obviamente
que continúa el extremos de la pandemia
yo creo que conforme se abra la economía
y se active la economía lo antes posible
pensamiento esto va a beneficiar a la
campaña a donald trump
independientemente del tema del cómic
creo que para para trump lo más
importante es que la economía se empieza
a recuperar lo antes posible que es lo
que realmente le puede llevar a ganar
otra vez las elecciones pues en este
momento todos nuestros invitados han
tenido ya dos intervenciones y quiero
volver entonces con nuestras
corresponsales en washington y en nueva
york y ya que hablábamos de nueva york
vamos a hablar de nuevo con mamen sala
nuestra corresponsal que está
permanentemente informado lo que ocurre
una gran manzana mamen y veíamos como el
tema del coi 19 hace parte de esta
campaña política así pero no muy
presente ha estado en la convención
republicana también nuestro invitado
jeffrey quien nos señalaba como las
gestiones del gobernador de nueva york
que no ha sido la mejor y como esta
ciudad se ha visto golpeada y eso tiene
con la administración demócrata que pues
ha dado ciertas medidas o ha tomado
ciertas medidas cuéntenos usted de
primera mano cómo se vive la pandemia
nueva york que está pasando hoy cuando
de pronto ya el foco no está puesto en
la cantidad de casos cada día que está
pasando y cómo esto se ha representado
en la decisión de los votantes
neoyorquinos
pues yo creo que la mejor manera de ver
lo que está ocurriendo no mayores
remitiéndonos a las cifras y las cifras
en este momento dicen que el estado de
nueva york lleva 16 días con un índice
de contagio por debajo del 1 por ciento
algo que difícilmente vemos en todos los
países de la unión europea en nueva yor
hemos contado ya con más de un día en el
que no ha habido ninguna muerte por kobe
19 en estos momentos los casos en eeuu
continúan subiendo en al menos 10
estados y después de esas terribles
cifras que vemos que son 58 millones de
contagios y más de 179 mil fallecidos a
la cabeza nuestra nueva york que fue el
epicentro de la pandemia sino california
texas y florida que son en estos
momentos los que desgraciadamente
capitanea en esas terribles cifras en
nueva yor sí que es verdad que fue el
epicentro de la pandemia pero poco a
poco se ha ido recuperando precisamente
se hacía referencia a ese encierro
fuerte que se hizo en nueva york y
precisamente por eso hemos conseguido
frenar el aumento de casos sí que es
verdad que la reapertura aquí está
ocurriendo de manera más lenta que en
otros lugares hemos visto que por
ejemplo en florida empezaron hace dos
semanas los niños el colegio y esto ha
dado lugar a que haya 9.000 casos nuevos
entre los pequeños aquí empezaremos el
10 de septiembre va a haber una
combinación entre híbrido y presencial
que todavía no está del todo definido
pero sí que es verdad que se está
actuando con mucha prudencia una
prudencia que al final está dando buenas
cifras como decías no hemos visto
todavía un plan encima de la mesa sobre
cómo se va a gestionar esta pandemia o
qué se va a hacer quien no se haya hecho
ya precisamente eso es una de las
críticas también desde el partido
demócrata que de momento no se ha puesto
encima de la mesa en todas en estas tres
jornadas ningún plan
estamos esperando también a ver cuál es
la intervención del vicepresidente
maipés que precisamente uno de los
puntos que se espera que trate en su
discurso es este la gestión que ha hecho
la casa blanca de esta crisis en la que
nos encontramos
amén usted nos hace un muy buen resumen
de cómo está la situación en este
momento de nueva york frente al coi 19
pero usted que está en el día a día que
está con los ciudadanos que están de los
periodistas que está en el diario vivir
de la gran manzana cuéntanos cómo podría
esto mover o movilizar el voto
newyorkino frente a la selección del 3
de noviembre y qué percepción hay entre
los newyorkinos que son bastante
diversos además hay que decirlo con
población de todas partes del mundo afro
descendientes afroamericanos latinos y
africanos de gente de oriente
así que cuéntenos un poco cómo después
darse ofrece dentro de la pandemia está
ubicado o cómo se está moviendo el voto
newyorkino después la situación tan
difícil hacia el próximo mes de
noviembre
tenemos que pensar que nueva york es un
estado mayoritariamente demócrata donde
más del 80% de la población ha votado en
los últimos años al partido en el último
elecciones al partido demócrata sí que
es verdad que se ve ese miedo en la
calle unas calles vacías completamente
inundadas por un silencio al que no
estamos acostumbrados en esta ciudad y
esto que ha dado lugar pues ha dado
lugar a que muchos neoyorquinos mayores
de 65 años hayan cambiado su voto y este
año según las encuestas ya no vayan a
votar por donald trump como lo hicieron
en el 2016 y tengamos en cuenta que este
voto de los mayores de 65 años tuvo
mucho que ver en el triunfo y donald
tram en 2016 así que ésta ha sido una de
las consecuencias de la gestión que está
haciendo donald trump de esta pandemia
por otro lado también tenemos que pensar
que como decía aquí en nueva york hay
una gran diversidad cultural hay una
gran población afroamericana y latina
que no debemos olvidar que han sido los
más castigados tanto por la pandemia
como por la crisis económica que ha
seguido a la crisis sanitaria y pues
muchos de ellos no se están viendo
reflejados
estos tres días de convención que
estamos viviendo porque como ya decíamos
el primer día poca presencia de
representantes latinos pocos discursos
encabezados a los derechos de los
latinos un poquito más de los
afroamericanos pero siempre desde el
punto de vista de las protestas que
hemos visto en por la no ahora en
wisconsin que se han tratado hasta el
momento de manera muy superficial así
que por supuesto que esta actuación por
parte de la casa blanca sobre la
pandemia está afectando al voto luego
también tenemos que tener en cuenta que
en nueva york está apostando muy fuerte
por la votación vía correo de hecho aquí
en nueva york se acaba de aprobar el
miedo a contagiarse de coronavirus como
una excusa para pedir el voto por correo
así que desde luego ha tenido sus
consecuencias y supongo que conforme
vaya pasando el tiempo seguirá teniendo
las así es mamen hemos visto como el
gobernador andrew cuomo ha autorizado y
hayamos promovido el voto por vía correo
electrónico también como una medida para
prevenir los espacios de telco y 19
vamos a ver ahora con diana castañeda
corresponsal en washington de france 24
día
para hablar un poco también de la
coyuntura de la coyuntura actual de lo
que ocurre hoy en este día en que
estamos viendo la tercera jornada de la
convención republicana pero también
estamos viendo como en la ciudad de que
no vienes en wisconsin pues se debaten
protestas nuevamente contra la simula
brutalidad policial donde tenemos dos
muertos heridos de bala un joven de 17
años menor de edad detenido por el
sospecha de haber sido quien asesinó
estas personas justamente con un arma de
fuego y la reacción del presidente de
tron que nuevamente hace referencia a
que no va a permitir saqueos ni
violencia ni desmanes ni anarquía como
pues es la forma en la que califica el
partido republicano este tipo de
manifestaciones como podemos ver lo que
se pone en escena en la tercera jornada
la reconvención republicana en
comparación con la coyuntura nacional
con lo que está ocurriendo hoy en el
país
si definitivamente estos hechos son un
reflejo no solamente de la coyuntura al
día de hoy sino de lo que hemos visto en
los pasados meses desde la muerte de
georg floyd y hay un contraste muy claro
entre el manejo que está dando el
presidente de donald trump frente a
estos hechos a la manera en la cual lo
manejo por ejemplo el partido demócrata
en su convención en donde veíamos una
gran cantidad de testimonios de personas
que y familiares que habían perdido a
sus seres queridos la mayoría de los
afroamericanos encuentros con la policía
e incluso vimos a los familiares de
floyd a hablar y hablar de unidad para
que no solamente salieran a votar a las
personas afroamericanas sino también
minorías como los latinos que también
sufren las consecuencias cuando se
enfrentan con la policía así que digamos
que hay una gran diferencia entre lo que
vemos del lado demócrata republicano
sobre este manejo pero definitivamente
si va a tener
en la votación y en la movilización
hacia las urnas ya que por ejemplo el
partido demócrata ha logrado tener el
respaldo de muchas bases de trabajadores
de uniones y sindicatos que son
afroamericanos y minorías que le están
dando el respaldo a un presidente
blanco a un candidato a la presidencia
como es yo bayrén así que lo que veremos
es si esto se traduce finalmente el
próximo noviembre 3 cuando se ven los
resultados de las votaciones si esta
unidad que está mostrando el partido
demócrata realmente va a llevar al
triunfo y al regreso del partido azul de
nuevo a la casa blanca por otro lado en
el caso de los republicanos el
presidente no solo ha enfrentado las
críticas por estos hechos que están
ocurriendo esta semana y que veremos
protestas en diversos estados durante el
fin de semana por estos hechos sino
también las críticas de como manejó a
los manifestantes
en la capital de los eeuu utilizando
gases para salir de la casa blanca
caminar y tomarse una foto en frente de
la iglesia tomando la biblia en la mano
lo cual fue criticado por muchos
miembros del congreso y también por
organizaciones que defienden los
derechos civiles así que detrás de este
movimiento también vemos una gran
cantidad de posibles votantes jóvenes
que no sólo están en descontento en la
manera como se han manejado estos hechos
relacionados con justicia racial sino
también en la manera en la cual la
administración ha manejado la pandemia
que deja a eeuu en una crisis profunda
económica donde hay muy pocas
oportunidades de trabajo en este momento
por las restricciones pero también hay
40 millones de personas que están
aplicando a subsidios de desempleo así
que no solamente es el arista de que
tanto afectará la pandemia
y la coyuntura de estos hechos por
justicia racial las votaciones sino
también el efecto que tiene la pandemia
en la economía en la movilidad que
podrán tener los votantes en las urnas y
en los derechos al voto debido a la
campaña que está realizando el
presidente de donald trump para según lo
expresan los demócratas desprestigiar el
voto a través de correo diana pues éste
toca dos puntos importantes y los hemos
visto también reflejado durante el orden
del día y la selección de los speakers
de esta tercera jornada de la convención
republicana y es temas jóvenes y temas
mujeres por supuesto sabemos que yo
bardem se había comprometido a elegir
una co equiper a una llave
vicepresidencial que fuera mujer y
además al ser afroamericana descendiente
de un jamaiquino pero también de una
mujer india tiene una raíz migrante muy
importante y es kamala harris una mujer
que además viene el sector judicial con
un bagaje muy importante en cuanto a lo
que también ha querido mostrar como su
mano dura su ley el orden pues ésta es
una mujer que también pone una
talanquera importante en este aspecto
además que los jóvenes son
principalmente los que han estado
marchando desde el pasado 25 de mayo en
contra del racismo y la violencia
policial jóvenes no solamente
afroamericanos sino jóvenes de
diferentes ascendencia digámoslo de esta
forma vemos que hoy en la lista de
speakers de invitados del partido
republicano y justamente una alta
cantidad de mujeres y también las
personas jóvenes del partido que han
estado brillando recientemente como
podemos pensar que ésta está puesta en
escena porque también entendamos que el
presidente trump tiene muy bien planeada
toda su convención y que ha aparecido en
ella todos los días como esta jornada
está también un poco dirigida a las
mujeres ya los jóvenes que son el
público que justamente ola o la
población votante por justamente que el
partido demócrata tiene un poquito más
de su lado en esta coyuntura
digamos que lo que mencionaba es muy
cierto que mala harris le inyectó ese
dinamismo no solamente carisma que tiene
también vaivén la lesión por la manera
en que durante las primarias ella pudo
contrarrestar digamos desenvolverse muy
bien en los debates previos a la
elección como tal la denominación
interna del partido y esto digamos que
va a ser un factor a su favor para lo
que vendrá de acá en adelante estos
próximos dos meses para las elecciones
pero también porque pueden movilizar a
esa base de minorías que representa no
solamente el ser afroamericana sino
también el ser hija de padres
inmigrantes en los eeuu
así que esto es muy importante para el
partido demócrata pero también dentro
del propio partido demócrata hay un
movimiento joven que estaba apoyando a
bernie sanders y lo que trataron de
mostrar los demócratas era esa unión
digamos entre los dos lados el ala más
tradicional y el ala más progresista
como lo mencionaba esperan se traduzca
en las urnas no como ocurrió en las
elecciones presidenciales anteriores
donde muchos seguidores de sanders y del
movimiento juvenil que había creado no
apoyaron a hillary clinton ahora bien en
esta convención republicana también
estamos viendo voces jóvenes de personas
que representan esa la más conservadora
que también hace parte del partido
republicano tradicionalmente y que sale
a relucir durante esta convención es
cierto que hay muchos jóvenes también
que siguen esta línea pero también hay
un descontento entre muchos jóvenes que
se han visto afectados por esta pandemia
no sólo por el tema laboral sino también
hay muchos jóvenes que se sienten
frustrados por los altos costos de las
matrículas en las universidades hay
muchos jóvenes que vieron como sus
compañeros o inmigrantes estudiantes que
vienen a los eeuu
pues estaban en riesgo de ser deportados
por las medidas del presidente de donald
trump e incluso de cancelarles
completamente sus visas y todo esto se
ha ido a las cortes hay otros temas que
con los cuales los jóvenes no están de
acuerdo en el país y es no solamente el
tema de la educación sino el acceso a la
salud aunque en medio de esta pandemia
muchos de ellos no han tenido efectos
severos como se ve en adultos mayores o
personas con preexistencias de este
virus y anna si han tenido han tenido
que enfrentar estos casos muy cercanos
en sus familias así que hay que tener en
cita no es un gran apoyo interno
enfilado unos minutos perdón que la
interrumpa diana por estamos escuchando
hablar trump ella es la esposa de eric
trump uno de los hijos del presidente
justamente donald trump participando
nuevamente un personaje de la familia
ella también es asesora de la casa
blanca así que vamos a escucharla en
este momento
me enseñaron que eeuu podría lograr todo
con trabajo y determinación feliz de ver
las oportunidad
es para mí están limitados sólo por el
tamaño de mi ambición que debía soñar
grande y eso hice esos sueños son los
que me llevaron a nueva york para que me
quede aquí me quieren igual si podía
llegar allí podía llegar a cualquier
parte del mundo y eso intentaba hacer
entera un día no hubiera imaginado que
hoy estuviera en este lugar
y que tuviera el apellido trump y está
mi profesora de inglés me decía no crean
en todo lo que escuchan
sólo la mitad lo que leen esas palabras
no las entendía hasta que me conocí a mi
esposo y la familia trump
cualquier idea que tenía antes de ellos
desapareció
ellos eran grandes trabajadores
me recordaron a mi propia familia me
sintieron que estaban hicieron sentir
que estaba en casa trabajando la
organización trump vi ese mismo ambiente
familiar
vi la cantidad de mujeres que trabajaban
el género no importaba lo que importaba
era la habilidad de hacer el trabajo
bueno aprendiz directamente con el 2016
mi suegro me pidió que lo ayudara a
ganar
en carolina del norte aunque no tenía
experiencia política creyó en mí
lewis que él sabía que yo era capaz
incluso si yo no sabía lo que no me
sorprende no me sorprendió con el
presidente de donald trump apoyo a
tontos mujeres en su gobierno las
etiqueta de naciones unidos secretaria
la primera mujer negra en que ya tenemos
y una gran cantidad de mujeres en todo
el gobierno
tomeu esclavos en world words y fútbol
intermedien y 4.3 mil millones de
dólares ni 29 de empleos se crearon
en prime time en sexo entre 16.000
mujeres
han salido la pobreza todos desde que
asumió la presidencia esto lo hizo para
ganar votos hasta lo hizo el señor que
son las cosas que se deben hacer
cien años atrás
la enmienda 19 fue ratificada para
permitirle voto a todas las mujeres y
desde entonces
se han hecho grandes logros por las
mujeres en eeuu desde el rosa park a
sally ride en las mujeres al moldear la
historia de eeuu y la han hecho
excepcional a nivel mundial
me miró a mí misma mi juventud
allí miro ahora lo que me digo ahora
ahora que nos dirigimos a la elección
más crítica en la historia moderna esto
no es una elección entre republicanos y
demócratas entre izquierda y derecha es
una elección que voy a decidir si
mantenemos a eeuu como eeuu
o si caemos en una camino del socialismo
abraham lincoln dijo que eeuu nunca va a
ser destruida desde afuera si perdemos
nuestra libertad
será porque nosotros mismos la
destruimos porque no con que esas
palabras se hicieron hace más de 150
años nunca han sido más relevantes si
escogemos el camino de oportunidades de
libertad y de libertad que hacen este
país el más grande del mundo si
mantenemos la esperanza de aquellos que
luchan la opresión el comunismo y la
tiranía
no sólo como un miembro de la familia
trump sino como una mujer que trabaja en
sus bases y que aspira a seguir
creciendo cuando miro a mi hijo luke y a
mi hija carolina
ahí viviendo qué país le voy a dejar a
ellos a nuestras futuras generaciones
sin uy en los últimos meses hemos visto
una gran casa
de políticos y alentando a las
manifestaciones desmantelar la policía y
es lo mejor para el partido demócrata
joe biden no va a hacer lo necesario
para mantener el orden para mantener
seguros a nuestros hijos en los
vecindarios y las escuelas para
restaurar nuestra vida estadounidense
no podremos soñar nuestros sueños
grandes por estar preocupados por la
seguridad de todos nosotros
ya que se mantendrá eeuu sana y segura
mantendrá eeuu prospera el presidente
camps va a mantener eeuu como eeuu están
viendo y sin dudando de su voto no se
dejen guiar por las noticias
escuchen a alguien que lo sabe yo soy
del sur de escuelas públicas y trabaje
en un ies fui una universidad estatal y
mi profesora tenía razón lo que aprendí
de nuestro presidente es diferente a lo
que ustedes han escuchado él es un buen
hombre él ama a su familia y que no
necesitaba este trabajo que nadie
trabaja tan fuerte por el pueblo
estadounidense que está dispuesto a
luchar por sus creencias por el pueblo
por el país que él ama y él es una
persona con convicción es un luchador y
no va a atenerse ahora davis es luchar
por eeuu en hip hop para proteger a
nuestras familias y un inmune dhabi
perfect enzo para tener y nuestro país
no va a ser perfecto hasta que la
oportunidad de hacer equitativa para
todos incluidos especialmente las
mujeres estar en presidente ronald
reagan lo dijo lo mejor los sueños de
las personas difieren pero todos quieren
que sus sueños se hagan realidad ningún
eeuu ciudad nos da la oportunidad de
hacer eso
nosotros debemos hacer eso para nuestros
hijos y las futuras generaciones a mi
suegro gracias por creer en mí
gracias por liderar este país y gracias
por seguir luchando cada día por eeuu
que dios bendiga a todos los estados que
dios bendiga a las tropas y que dios
siga bendiciendo a este increíble país
escuchamos las palabras de lara trump
ella es la esposa de eric trump y
también asesora de campaña del
presidente de donald trump como ella
misma lo dijo durante su campaña a las
elecciones de 2016 vemos cómo vuelve un
poco el tono que veníamos viendo las dos
primeras jornadas de esta convención
republicana lo que vimos el pasado lunes
y también ayer martes de la familia
trump integrantes de la familia entre
ellos su esposa sus hijos y hablando un
poco a favor de él pero es una forma muy
importante resaltando el tema de la
seguridad vamos a hablar con nuestros
invitados y vamos a volver con jose
bastos para analizar el discurso de la
noche mientras esperamos la intervención
del vicepresidente mike pence 11 vasos
desde washington de zinc
vemos justamente lo que veníamos
hablando con ustedes un momento y es que
hoy estamos trayendo un poquito a la
familia tu aunque su presidente de las
dos primeras jornadas y que son ellos
los que han tenido los discursos tal vez
más directos más en fuertes promoviendo
la seguridad la ley y el orden que
promueve el gobierno republicano donald
trump y un poco
indicando que la campaña demócrata va a
dejar perder dicha seguridad como vemos
entonces que vuelve a reforzar se vuelve
a retomarse lo que veíamos viendo en las
dos primeras jornadas usted qué opina
sí creo que este discurso del de lara
trump fue mucho más personal no hablando
de las de las oportunidades o el impulso
que ha dado trompa a las mujeres ya
colocándose como un ejemplo en eso y
creo que sin duda es un mensaje que va
dirigido a mujeres en eeuu probablemente
más específicamente a mujeres blancas y
de ustedes de mayores recursos no y de
mayor nivel educativo que tengan que es
un voto que ha sido históricamente
republicano pero que se ha ido moviendo
al partido demócrata que trump perdió en
el año 2016 y que perdió aún más el
partido republicano en las elecciones
del congreso del 2018 no el partido
porque no sabe que tiene que al menos
recortar esa diferencia recuperar parte
del voto femenino para poder ganar la
reelección el año 2020 y me parece que
este discurso y lo que hemos visto sobre
todo hoy tantas mujeres en posiciones
relevantes dentro del gobierno o de la
campaña resaltando el rol digamos de
trump e impulsando a las mujeres es que
sea un mensaje creíble o no para la
mayoría del país bueno creo que creo que
queda abierta esa pregunta no obviamente
los los críticos a trump
es muy sexista que es que no le dais
impulso a las mujeres pero sin duda la
campaña sabe que esa es una debilidad
muy grande y aunque no vayan a ganar el
voto de la mujer necesitan al menos
recuperar parte del voto que han perdido
y como mencionaba el tema de la
seguridad es uno que interesa mucho
bueno a todo el país por ahí ha
intentado mezclar es el interés de
recuperar cierto voto femenino con el
riesgo de la de la inseguridad creciente
que que hay en ciertas ciudades del país
bueno vamos a hablar del mismo tema
gracias jose bastos con jeffrey quien es
y le vamos a preguntar entonces como el
voto femenino está en este momento
marcando la diferencia podría dado el
caso marcar la diferencia para las dos
campañas por supuesto que al tener joe
biden una candidata vicepresidencial
mujer y parte de la diversidad por ser
afro afroamericana y por ser también
hija de migrantes pues tiene pues una
concentración ahí de un pugna posible de
población votante en cambio como
queremos o como podemos analizar que
está representando a la mujer hoy en
esta tercera jornada
los republicanos hay una diferencia
definitivamente de partido demócrata
tiene ya ganado el voto femenino con la
candidatura de kamala harris la mujer
inteligente tanto como el hombre
inteligente no vota por el color y no
vota por el sexo vota porque confía en
que esa persona a la cual está
entregando la confianza con el voto le
va a hacer el trabajo y le va a cumplir
las promesas que esta persona necesita o
sea que pensar que porque es mujer las
mujeres van a votar por ella de eso no
tiene sentido lo que lo mismo sucedió
con hillary clinton ella pensaba que el
100 por ciento de las mujeres en eeuu
iban a votar por ella pero no sucedió
eso y mira hablando del voto de la mujer
y el sexismo kamala harris durante las
primarias demócratas que le fue muy mal
acusó al señor your by joe biden de
haber molestado mujeres y han salido
varias mujeres a decir si este señor me
atacó sexualmente
no hizo lo otro
durante la convención demócrata trajeron
al señor bill clinton acusado de
violación y ahora en medio de un
escándalo con el lolita exprés y este
señor que se suicidó que era un
proxeneta jeffrey james ley entonces el
mensaje está confuso dentro de la
plataforma de marketing político del
partido demócrata y no les va a ir bien
con el voto femenino no les va a ir bien
les va a ir muy mal porque su mensaje
nuevamente como en la campaña anterior
está mal enfocado está mal enfocado
ellos siguen pensando que por ser mujer
tienes que votar por por una mujer si
eres amarillo tienes que votar por un
amarillo
si eres verde tienes que votar por un
verde pero el elector americano es más
inteligente que eso muchísimo más
inteligente que eso y otra cosa otra
cosa no hay nada mejor para una mujer
que caminar por las calles en seguridad
eso se ha perdido en este momento puede
ser un pregunto a mis amigas me dice no
no voy a tal lugar porque me siento
inseguro he visto
cumbre en la esquina que están con
carteles diciendo black light mother que
tú me acusas que soy el otro no salgo y
es van a votar por champ dice no yo
quiero regresar a mi vida normal quiero
estar segura quiero poder ir a tomarme
un café que esté abierto el café quiero
poder ir a hacer compras caminar subirme
al metro sin que nadie me moleste quiero
subir quiero manejar mi carro sin que
nadie me pare en esquina a decirme oye
tú me estás abusando de una persona que
no te ha conocido en ningún momento de
tu vida te pare el skin dice tú me
abuses tú me abusas simplemente por el
color de tu piel y eso es realmente
absurdo eso es realmente absurdo absurdo
absurdo y por eso y yo apuesto a que el
voto femenino va a ir por el partido
republicano
esta vez muchísimo más que antes a mucho
más que la elección anterior en la cual
la señora hillary clinton llamó al y la
señora michelle obama llamó a las
mujeres que no habían votado por
ellas por hillary deplorables o sea las
insultó dijo así lo viene repitiendo
varias durante varias varias el curso de
los años en varias oportunidades tu no
votaste es por mí por ser mujer tú eres
un hombre una persona de pro ahora
deplorable simplemente porque no pudo
contactarse en la ideología con la mujer
de los eeuu y eso me parece que ahora el
castigo el castigo de los votantes va a
ser mucho más fuerte entonces hay que
tener cuidado con eso y no lo han
corregido hasta el momento no lo han
corregido sigamos apuntando por el color
ahora por la iniquidad y otras cosas
pues fantásticas y absurdas
sí pero señor quienes tenemos que anotar
también que durante todo el mundo el
movimiento mixto en el año 2017 también
hubo ciertas acusaciones aunque no
formales contra el presidente donald
trump y también durante esos tres años y
medio varios colaboradores cercanos del
presidente thomas resultado también
envuelto en este tipo de denuncias
aunque no se han hecho digamos efectivas
desde la parte de juego
entonces también hay sectores del
feminismo que critican el accionar del
presidente de trump entonces tenemos
quisiera que usted rápidamente me dé su
opinión frente a eso porque tenemos un
nuevo discurso en este momento pero tú
responsable rápidamente tú me estás
hablando de feminismo no de feminismo el
feminismo es un movimiento radical en
este momento y es un movimiento
totalmente comunista socialista es lo
que es el feminismo y el feminismo
ahorita y que es el movimiento mito el
movimiento me tunas nació en hollywood y
luego el principal acusado de este
movimiento fue este señor weinstein un
productor de películas muy rico
millonario en hollywood muy amigo de
hillary clinton y de bill clinton cuando
se descubrió eso el movimiento de mitú
desapareció inmediatamente
por favor corrígeme si el movimiento de
mitú ahorita suena si tiene dinero para
realizar alguna campaña política ha
desaparecido totalmente cuando la
conexión entre los clinton
james y weinstein se unió fotos y
testimonios y tu se desvaneció
inmediatamente y ahí están las pruebas
donde está el movimiento me to a diseñar
bueno pues vamos a ir justamente perdón
que lo interrumpa en este momento a
escuchar a richard greene el él es el ex
director de la agencia nacional de
inteligencia quienes se dirige entonces
en este momento a la población
norteamericana un sistema global en
nuestras ciudades industrias fueron
saqueadas las comunidades comunidades
fueron devastadas
las plantas de manufactura fueron
enviadas a china
es lo que sucede cuando washington se
tiene hacer esto y no es la capital de
eeuu sino es la capital del mundo
en alemania si fui testigo de la
política exterior de donald trump
beber como negociaba en nombre de los
estadounidenses vi como son encantaba a
la canciller alemana mientras insistía
que alemania debía pagar sus
obligaciones en la otan
estuve cuando trope le dijo que no
juzgó estados unidos para que sus
obligaciones pero conmigo se detiene no
voy a dejar que la gente que paga
impuestos pague esto es triste la
administración de donald trump siempre
ha sido muy clara que nuestra prioridad
equipo es la seguridad del pueblo
estadounidense
ese es el trabajo de todos los líderes
poner a su pueblo primero hemos visto
como estrategia ha tenido éxito en los
pocos cuatros años han logrado incluso
algunos demócratas estén de acuerdo en
la amenaza china
en las alianzas
y que tienen una responsabilidad en
cuatro años
trump no comenzó ni inició ninguna
guerra reconstruyó el ejército y firmó
acuerdos de paz que hicieron eeuu más a
salvo
y llaman a esta política nacionalismo
todo lo que necesitan saber
cuando los demócratas llama a trump
nacionalista creen que los insultan
como si el presidente de eeuu no debería
basarse en el interés de los propios
estadounidenses
los demócratas le dieron dinero a la cob
y al gobierno tirano de irán miles de
dólares de inversión
hizo una maniobra similar con un avión
pero era muy diferente a ésta
cuando aquellos que buscan la libertad
toman riesgo personal como en hong kong
terán o minsk no hay duda alguna words
cuál es el apoyo de la administración
trump equipo siempre vamos a estar con
la persona con las personas que luchen
por sus libertades
no se dejen engañar el establishment de
washington quiere venderles a su
candidato
joe biden fue elegido al senado en 1972
48 años atrás
es la típica historia de washington este
año 222 demócratas se lanzaron como
candidatos
washington y eligieron esa moneda al
último
que ya debería retirarse joe biden
ofrece ofrece una nueva idea pero por
qué no pensó eso en los últimos 4 48
años
hoy los demócratas culpan la pandemia
creciente trump que empezó en china y
culpan el fenómeno con rusia cuando fue
algo de hillary clinton
lo que vi por parte los demócratas
me hizo enfermar la administración obama
biden lanzó una campaña secreta contra
trump y silencio aquellos que iban a
hablar en contra de eso me presentaron
información falsa mintieron a los jueces
y clasificaron todo lo que podría
perjudicarlos y luego que trump ganó la
elección cuando debían continuar con la
tradición de ayudar
presidente y en su transición a la casa
blanca lo que hicieron fue obstaculizar
aún más
pidió ocultar
la información tres de tres semanas
antes de la inauguración de la nueva
administración
wang timbre ellos no han querido que los
estadounidenses sepan quién tomar las
acciones pero control siempre van a
saber quién está a cargo porque la
respuesta es ustedes
son ustedes los que están a cargo no los
intereses personales ni quienes apoyan a
china ni los fanáticos de la
globalización con donald trump y con
vent en la casa blanca
el pueblo es el jefe
la política exterior de trump es estado
en eeuu primero y no en el interés de un
grupo sobre el interés de otro no es
sobre rojo o azul educados o no educados
eeuu primero es la creencia que los
políticos deben enfocarse en la igualdad
y dignidad de todos los estadounidenses
y que este deber debe hacerse con la
responsabilidad de seguridad de todos
america first eso es eeuu primero esa es
la doctrina de trump y eso mis amigos es
4 años más
[Música]
estábamos escuchando en este especial
informativo en france24 acerca de la
convención republicana en su tercera y
penúltima jornada a richard grainger él
es el ex director de la agencia nacional
de inteligencia de eeuu y por su puesto
atrás sobre la mesa un tema muy
importante en esta campaña electoral
y se trata del tema de política exterior
vemos un discurso y quiero hablar esto
con nuestros invitados de la noche vemos
un discurso bastante similar al de nikki
haley en la primera jornada de esta
convención republicana el pasado lunes
ella es la ex representante de eeuu ex
embajadora de eeuu ante la onu quien
habla justamente de la relación con
china la relación con irán como si
llegan los demócratas al gobierno de
eeuu entonces puede perderse el control
perderse la soberanía estadounidense
perderse estas estos avances que ha
hecho tromba en materia de seguridad
especialmente con países justamente como
china y como irán vamos hablar con
joseba sobre este tema invitado en este
especial informativo y cómo es que el
partido republicano nos está
digamos proponiendo a la audiencia
una pérdida de la seguridad no sólo a
nivel interno con todo el tema
manifestaciones y con todo el tema de
seguridad pues del día a día de la de la
cotidianidad estadunidense sino también
a nivel de la política exterior con
países como china y como irán
sí bueno ha sido parte de la campaña
desde el inicio de un trompo hace cuatro
años desde estos eeuu primero a
enfocarse más en su país que en temas
exteriores en cierto sentido creo que es
cierto que que ha buscado
alejarse de algunas crisis externas no
enfocarse realmente en temas de
estadounidenses o siempre que la
política exterior sea más con el punto
de vista económico de frente que ha sido
el caso con china realmente la economía
ha sido la prioridad con el tema de las
tarifas y desde negociar el tratado y
como las las productos de importación
digamos no tenga ventaja china en cuanto
a la seguridad realmente no ha sido el
principal enfoque en cuanto a china de
hecho la relación entre entre el líder
chino y trompe en general ha sido
positiva y muchos críticos más bien
dicen que que se ha mencionaba muy poco
algunos digamos amenazas en temas de
seguridad de china o incluso la
violación de derechos humanos dentro del
china el presidente otro incluso en los
primeros días de la crisis de
coronavirus estaba aplaudiendo la
respuesta que había dado el gobierno
debe xi jinping entonces en temas
realmente el tema de la seguridad en la
relación con china no ha sido por
ciertamente ha sido una postura mucho
más dura el gobierno de obama compañero
de vicepresidente buscó una negociación
que bueno ellos lograron un acuerdo para
retirar las armas nucleares para
monitorear y también la en el tema
nuclear
trump siempre lo criticó o parecería
digamos lógico pensar que algún gobierno
de bailén buscaría más en la negociación
que la mano dura no en el tema de irán
al igual que nosotros pero incluso en el
mencionaba el tema de bielorrusia por
ejemplo que estamos viendo las protestas
en estos días y realmente el gobierno
entrando tampoco ha sido muy ha mostrado
realmente su apoyo contundente a esas
manifestaciones no entonces creo que en
algunos temas es cierto lo que es lo que
he estado comentando de que si ha habido
una mano dura del gobierno de tropas
sean cuáles sean los resultados y que va
a ir en ciertamente buscaría más una
negociación sobre todo en el caso del
gobierno de irán
bueno es la opinión de joseba sos desde
washington dc y vamos a ir hasta ahora a
la transmisión en directo desde la
convención republicana que por supuesto
se desarrolla manera virtual porque
estamos viendo imágenes de mike pence
actual vicepresidente de eeuu actual ya
ve vicepresidencial también de
presidente strong para la nueva elección
en los próximos cuatro años quien se
juega un papel muy importante en esta
noche su primera intervención y nuestros
días de convención republicana y además
porque él es el encargado el designado
por el presidente de trump para
enfrentar la pandemia alcoy 19 para
diseñar el dispositivo de respuesta al
coi 19 una jornada importante en la que
se está hablando de la tierra de héroes
podemos pensar que el discurso de mike
pence el vicepresidente va a estar
también enfocado en resaltar el accionar
de los que han estado enfrentando la
pandemia en primera línea y se espera
pues la opinión pública espera que el
tanto de cuál será la estrategia para la
para el gobierno actual en su segundo
período presidencial si es que logran es
reelegirse cuál será la estrategia para
enfrentar las pandemias ahora no se pone
una estrategia de gobierno o un plan del
gobierno camps para los próximos cuatro
años en caso de ser reelegidos para
enfrentar la pandemia alcoy 19 así que
en este momento vemos en pantalla un
vídeo pre de preámbulo pero parece ser
que en este momento tendremos ya en
directo las palabras de mike pence
vicepresidente de eeuu vamos en directo
a escuchar sus palabras
[Aplausos]
[Música]
el presidente de eeuu mike pence
acompañada por la segunda dama
la señora que era temps
[Aplausos]
[Música]
por qué
[Aplausos]
buenas noches eeuu
es un honor hablar para ustedes esta
noche desde el fuerte mcnair y el lugar
de la batalla que inspiró las palabras
de nuestro himno nacional esas palabras
que han inspirado esta tierra de héroes
en todas las generaciones y fue en este
lugar 206 años atrás
nuestros republicanos lucharon contra un
bombardeo
quisieron dividir nuestra nación y
terminar el experimento estadounidense
los héroes que estuvieron en este fuerte
lucharon con su vida libertad
y la bandera estadounidense
y eso define nuestra nación
pero casi no son nombrados en la
reciente convención demócrata demócrata
lo que hicieron fue atacar durante
cuatro días a eeuu joe biden dijo que
estábamos viviendo una temporada de
oscuridad pero como dijo el presidente
tronco donde yo vaivén de la oscuridad
nosotros vemos la grandeza de eeuu
en estos tiempos difíciles nuestro país
necesita un presidente que crea en eeuu
que crean las capacidades del pueblo
estadounidense encontrarse en nuevos
retos nuevos retos y defender las
libertades que atesoramos eeuu necesita
cuatro años más de presidente
trump en la casa blanca
[Aplausos]
antes de avanzar déjenme decir algo a
las familias
que hoy se verán afectadas por el
huracán laura y nuestras oraciones están
con ustedes nuestra administración está
trabajando con las autoridades locales
hemos movilizado
y sus fondos para estos lugares esto es
una tormenta difícil y fuerte
manténganse a salvo y sepan que vamos a
estar con ustedes en cada paso para
apoyarlos rescatar responder y
recuperarnos en los próximos días y
semanas eso es lo que hacen los
estadounidenses
hace cuatro años respondí la llamada
para unirme a esto porque sabía que en
su creía en su liderazgo y en su visión
de hacer eeuu más grande en los últimos
cuatro años he visto a este presidente
recibir gran cantidad de ataques pero
levantarse para seguir luchando y
logrando las promesas que le hizo al
pueblo estadounidense así que con la
gratitud y la confianza que él me ha
dado el apoyo de nuestro partido
republicano y de dios'
aceptó la nominación para servir como
vicepresidente de eeuu
[Aplausos]
en esta oficina era un viaje que no me
esperaba es un viaje que no hubiera sido
posible sin el apoyo de mi familia
comenzando por mi esposa increíble
carmen
ella es una profesora una gran madre de
nuestros tres hijos
y es una sobresaliente segunda dama dama
de los eeuu
en wickford y no podríamos estar más
orgullosos de nuestros tres hijos
dennis wasser
nuestra hija charlotte pensión
y esposa del teniente
y de nuestro más joven nuestra hija
y su prometido como muchos otros
estadounidenses tuvieron que posponer su
boda
pero no podemos esperar para quedarse
aparte de nuestra familia
my wife and hills
esto se suma a las personas la persona
que más me ha ayudado en esta vida mi
madre nancy
ella es la hija de un inmigrante
irlandés
mi madre sigue la política muy de cerca
y que la verdad sea dicha algunas veces
pero creo que soy su segundo candidato
favorito en esta carrera
pence gracias mamá te amo
en los últimos cuatro años tenía el
privilegio de trabajar cerca con nuestro
presidente y verlo cuando no hay cámaras
alrededor en eeuu
trump de diferentes maneras pero no hay
duda como trump de eeuu ve a eeuu por lo
que es una nación que ha hecho más bien
que cualquiera en el mundo una nación
que merece mayor gratitud y si quieren
un presidente que mantenga el silencio
cuando insultan a nuestro país pues este
no va a ser su presidente
[Aplausos]
después
en algunas personas creen que nosotros
somos diferentes
pero he aprendido algo al verlo
cómo trata todo lo que hemos vivido en
los últimos tres años y medio él hace
las cosas a su manera bajo sus propios
términos
casi nada pasa de largo y cuando tiene
una opinión
él no duda en decirlo él mantiene todo
interesante pero lo más importante
el presidente de donald trump ha
mantenido su palabra al pueblo de eeuu
en una ciudad conocida por habladores el
presidente de trump es alguien que hace
y muy pocos presidentes han traído mayor
independencia energía y determinación a
esa oficina
hace cuatro años se le damos un ejército
vacío
una economía luchando por salir de sus
crisis controlaba
un terreno dos veces mayor que
pensilvania
vivimos amenazados nuestra libertad de
religión
a eso se enfrentó el presidente cuando
llegó hoy desde el primer día
reconstruyó nuestro ejército
este presidente firmó el mayor aumento
desde ronald reagan y creó la nueva rama
de fuerzas armadas en 70 años por las
fuerzas espaciales de los eeuu
[Aplausos]
y con esa energía volvimos con nuestros
astronautas al espacio luego de cerca de
10 años
en el reverso buscando y luego de años
de escándalo del cuidado a los veteranos
el presidente de toma tuvo su palabra
otra vez
reformamos en el sistema y ahora es
disponible para cualquier veterano en
eeuu
[Aplausos]
nuestras fuerzas armadas y veteranas y
veteranos son los héroes de nuestra
nación y mucho nos acompaña en el día de
hoy hoy tenemos cuatro personas que
recibieron la medalla de honor
y que han recibido el corazón púrpura
[Aplausos]
una persona que recibió la estrella de
oro
y soldados heridos
[Aplausos]
estamos asombrados con su presencia y
les agradecemos por su servicio
[Aplausos]
como estos hemos defendido a nuestra
nación todos los días con este
comandante mi jefe
hemos luchado
con los islamistas radicales en su
territorio
destruimos su califato y destruimos su
califato y destruimos y dimos de baja el
líder sin dar de baja a ningún
estadounidense y estuve allí cuando
presienten trump
la orden del mayor terrorista iraní
en la historia porque qasem soleimani ya
no está
acabó con su desordenado
deben saber que yo voy de cryptic
critico a trump por estas decisiones
decisiones que dieron fin a dos
terroristas mundiales pero no es
sorpresa porque joe biden se opuso a la
operación que dio de baja osama bin
laden
no es sorpresa que el secretario defensa
bajo la administración obama biden dijo
que había sido
ya que habías hecho todo el mal en la
política exterior en los últimos cuatro
años así que nos enfrentamos a nuestros
enemigos y nos paramos junto a nuestros
aliados
y así como cuando el trump movió la
embajada estadounidense a jerusalén
[Aplausos]
y reconociendo a israel como un estado
futuro más cercano a casa
[Aplausos]
apoyamos nuestro el sentido de la vida
y cuando se trata de la economía el
presidente de trump mantuvo su palabra e
hizo algo más e hicimos el mayor recorte
de impuestos
desatamos de energía eeuu
y luchamos por el libre comercio
jobs se ha creado 7 mil millones de
buenos empleos
inclusive miles de
empresas manufactureras en todo el
territorio estadounidense
el país se convirtió en exportador de
energía
el desempleo de los hispanos es el más
bajo en años
estoy orgulloso de decir que bajo el
president hecho en sex tenemos la tasa
más baja de desempleo
femenino en los últimos años
y cada vez más estadounidenses
trabajando en los últimos tres años
creamos la economía más fuerte y más
grande hicimos que eeuu volviera a ser
grande
y luego nos golpeó el coronavirus desde
china
antes del primer caso llegará a eeuu el
presidente tomó acción sin precedente y
suspendió todos los viajes desde china
la segunda economía más grande del mundo
esa acción salvó vidas estadounidenses y
después decir de primera mano nos compró
tiempo para lanzar la movilización más
grande desde la segunda guerra mundial
él dirigió
una alianza con los gobernadores de todo
el país de ambos partidos
el apoyo la reinvención de las pruebas
estoy esperando
hoy estamos haciendo más de 800.000
pruebas al día y hemos coordinado
miles de tours de kits de protección
para las personas que trabajan en la
salud de enfermeros y médicos
[Aplausos]
vendimos ventiladores en 100 días y
nadie que necesitaba un ventilador le
fue negado un ventilador en eeuu
[Aplausos]
construimos hospitales
hicimos un acuerdo para salvar más de 70
millones de empleos estadounidenses y
estamos desarrollando tratamientos
terapéuticos como el plasma
convaleciente que está salvando vidas en
todo eeuu la semana pasada a joe biden
dijo
no mejor que come
no viene ningún milagro bueno yo parece
no entender es que eeuu es una nación de
milagros
y esté orgulloso de decir que estamos en
camino de tener la vacuna contra el
coronavirus a finales de este año
[Aplausos]
después de todo el sacrificio en este
año como ninguno ningún otro
estamos encontrando nuestra forma de
seguir adelante pero esta noche nuestros
corazones están con todos aquellos que
han perdido familiares o queridos y que
tienen familiares que están luchando
contra las enfermedades en este país
estamos de luto con aquellos que están
de luto
en esta noche sé que millones de
estadounidenses han sido golpeados y
nosotros oramos por ustedes
nuestro país
nos supera un tiempo así a no ser que
las personas se encuentren la fuerza
dentro de sí la respuesta de médicos
enfermeras y agricultores camioneros y
de todos los estadounidenses
que ponen la salud y la seguridad
primero no ha sido nada menos que un
acto heroico
[Aplausos]
veronica se pone su atuendo todos los
días
trabajando en uno de los hospitales más
concurridos de nueva york se mantuvo en
su trabajo trabajando por horas hasta
que su trabajo estaba hecho y volvía a
su barrio y ayudaba a vecinos y amigos
que lo necesitaban su hermano william es
un bombero de nueva york y los dos son
emblemas de los héroes que hay en este
país
están con nosotros aquí esta noche y les
digo a ellos ya todos ustedes ustedes se
han ganado la admiración del pueblo
estadounidense y siempre vamos a estar
agradecidos por su servicio y su cuidado
[Aplausos]
gracias al coraje compasión del pueblo
estadounidense estamos deteniendo
el esparcimiento y protegemos a los
vulnerables y estamos reabriendo eeuu
presión por los fundamentos que ha
puesto el presidente tronco
hemos ganado 9.3 millones de empleos en
los últimos tres meses solamente
y nos estamos reabriendo eeuu estamos
reabriendo las escuelas
usted orgulloso de decir que mi esposa
karen la profesora con la que estoy
casado va a volver a su clase la próxima
semana así como todos los otros
profesores heroicos el staff fue gracias
por estar allí para nuestros hijos vamos
a estar con ustedes en cada paso de este
camino
en los próximos días mientras reabrimos
eeuu nuevamente les prometo que vamos a
poner la seguridad y la sanidad primero
todos tenemos una lección que hacer
en noviembre 3 tienen que preguntarse a
quién en quien confían para reconstruir
la economía un político de carrera
o un líder que se ha probado que ha
creado la mayor economía del mundo la
elección es clara debe volver a eeuu más
grande necesitamos cuatro años más de
presidente el donald trump en la casa
blanca
[Aplausos]
mis compatriotas estamos pasando un
tiempo de prueba en medio de esta
pandemia mundial
mientras nuestra nación se está
recuperando
hemos visto violencia y caos en las
calles de nuestras principales ciudades
el presidente camps y yo siempre vamos a
apoyar el derecho de la sep pero de
protestar se pacíficamente
romper el caos y los disturbios no son
las pacíficas protestas
destruir estatuas no es libertad de
expresión aquellos que lo hagan van a
ser judicial izados
la semana pasada yo verdad no dijo ni
una sola palabra acerca de la violencia
y el caos en varias ciudades de este
país así que déjenme hacerle claros
la violencia debe detenerse ya sea a
mineápolis portland o que muchos héroes
han muerto defendiendo a nuestra nación
para ver a los estadounidenses unos
contra otros vamos a tener ley y orden
en las calles de nuestro país para todos
los estadounidenses de cada raza de cada
credo y de cada color
fue presidente trump y yo sabemos que
las mujeres y los hombres que usan el
uniforme de las autoridades son los
mejores cada día cuando salen por la
puerta consideran las vidas de los demás
más importante que las de ellos mismos
una vida como dave para ser un oficial
en el departamento
de protección que fue asesinado durante
los disturbios en california
y el heroísmo de él es emblemático de
los héroes que sirven al país
angela te decimos a ti
que estamos de luto contigo y que eeuu
no va a olvidar ni va a fallar en honrar
al oficial de patrick underworld
el pueblo estadounidense lo sabe
no debemos elegir entre apoyar a las
autoridades que no tenemos y apoyar a
nuestros vecinos afrodescendientes eddie
cage yo aprobar la educación más empleo
seguridad y desde el primer día de esta
administración hemos hecho las dos cosas
y vamos a seguir manteniendo la ley el
orden y seguir apoyando a las minorías a
los seres afrodescendientes durante en
todo este país durante cuatro años más
[Aplausos]
bardem dice que eeuu es sistemáticamente
racista
y que las autoridades han dado un
impulso varias
quienes manuales
tienen una parcialidad en cuanto a
recortar los fondos para las policías él
dijo que sí absolutamente
no mejor que ustedes
y la verdad es que ustedes no van a
estar seguros en eeuu joe biden
siempre vamos a estar con aquellos que
están en la primera línea y no vamos a
desmantelar la policía no ahora ni nunca
[Aplausos]
mis compatriotas estamos pasando un
tiempo de prueba pero pronto vamos a
tener un tiempo para escoger mucho piden
se ha referido como el mismo como un
candidato de transición y muchos
preguntan una transición a que la semana
pasada los demócratas no hablaron mucho
sobre su agenda y si yo fuera uno de
ellos tampoco lo hubiera hecho
bernie sanders dijo a sus seguidores que
joe biden ser el presidente más liberal
de los tiempos modernos de hecho dijo
que muchas de las ideas por las que
luchaba y que hace algunos años eran
consideradas radicales y que ahora son
comunes en el partido demócrata en la
raíz de su agenda está la creencia que
eeuu está dirigido por envidia no
aspiración que millones de
estadounidenses
se sienten a sus vecinos en vez de
amarse
creen que el gobierno debe estar en la
vida de todos y deben dictar cómo vivir
como tienen su vida como trabajan como
deben criar a nuestros hijos
dejen de ver su agenda está basada en un
gobierno que controla todo
nuestra agenda está basada en la
libertad
[Aplausos]
el presidente trump recorta los
impuestos yo voy de pretende aumentarlos
cuando este presidente logra la
independencia energética
el presidente el vicepresidente biden
pretende eliminar el combustible fósil
lo que aumentaría el costo de las
familias trabajadores nosotros luchamos
por libre comercio y luchó ante china y
terminó con una era económica sometida
él quiere
el critica al presidente trono por
suspender todos los viajes a china
cuando inició esta pandemia yo bailé
para abrir fronteras
liberar abogados
e inmigrantes
y construyó 300.000 millas de ese muro
para proteger a estados unidos
crea que cualquier padre debe tener el
derecho elegir a qué escuela debe ir sin
importar sus ingresos o su lugar de
residencia
el presidente trompo
me ha apoyado la vida yo bailé dicho
baile en el apoyo
los fondos para los abortos cuando
ustedes consideran su agenda es clara
joe biden no va a ser nada más que un
caballo de troya para la izquierda
radical una elección nunca ha sido más
clara y las apuestas no han sido más
altas la semana pasada by ver lo que la
democracia la democracia está en juego y
que nuestra economía está en este voto
pero hay cosas más importantes y
fundamentales para nuestro país
de esta elección no es sobre si eeuu era
más liberal o más conservador más
republicano o más demócrata
la elección va a ser si estados unidos
se mantiene siendo eeuu
si le vamos a dejar a nuestros hijos y
nietos un país con los más altos ideales
de libertad comercios libertad de
comercio y les vamos a dejar que ha sido
fundamentalmente transformado en otra
cosa
estamos en una encrucijada eeuu el
presidente trump está en un camino de
oportunidad de libertad joe biden diría
y nos llevaría en un camino de
declinación
pero no vamos a dejar que eso suceda el
presidente de donald trump cree en eeuu
y en el pueblo de eeuu en el potencial
de vivir su sueño en libertad
reciente lucha cada día por mantener la
promesa de eeuu todos los días nuestro
presidente luchó para expandir
el alcance del sueño estadounidense cada
día
el presidente lucha por ustedes
y ahora es nuestro turno de luchar por
él
en esta noche acompañado por estos
héroes grave estoy muy agradecido y muy
agradecido por el privilegio de servir
como vicepresidente esta gran nación y
de tener la oportunidad de volver a
servir
voy a entregar todo para ese deber en el
año 2020
el pueblo estadounidense ha tenido una
gran cantidad de retos pero gracias y
tenemos un presidente que tiene la
determinación y la resolución para
llevarnos adelante
pero estas características están en
nuestro carácter nacional
en septiembre beijing fighting en
septiembre de 1914 bajo un bombardeo en
este fuerte nuestro
no soy el joven del país fue defendido
pues hasta ahora escuchamos el discurso
de mike pence vicepresidente de estados
unidos y por supuesto quien busca
reelegirse junto a donald trump hará
cuatro años más en el gobierno de la
unión americana por supuesto que aceptó
oficialmente la nominación republicana a
la vicepresidencia para la nueva
elección y además habló de temas muy
interesantes y que sabíamos que nos la
toca durante esta intervención en la
convención por supuesto habló al huracán
laura que se acerca a las costas de
luisiana y texas habló también de
el coi 19 y la del dispositivo de
respuesta a liderado por el presidente
de donald trump obviamente a través de
él también habló de los 9.3 millones de
empleos generados por el gobierno son
bajo su promesa general 10 millones de
empleos así que hubo como un como un
resumen completo de lo que ha sido hasta
ahora esta gestión de los primeros tres
años y medio de donald trump y malpensa
la cabeza de eeuu vamos a hablar con
estos invitados para una ronda de
conclusiones tras esta intervención y
empezamos entonces conejo con jesús
garza desde monterrey en méxico que nos
está acompañando del principio de este
especial informativo en france 24 señor
el señor jesús garza como intérprete
usted cómo evalúa usted esta respuesta
que le a mike pence puntualmente
hablándole a joe biden diciendo que tú
vas de en donde él ve la luz donde la
oscuridad del partido republicano de la
luz hablando de temas de política
exterior hablando de temas de seguridad
y poniendo por supuesto en entredicho
todas las propuestas del partido
demócrata como usted analiza estar este
discurso
y yo creo que como bien dices yo sí
critico mucho hasta que encanta mucho la
postura y yo bailé pero otra vez el
énfasis principal del partido
republicano y sobre todo lo que dijo
pence el desempleo mínimos casi
históricos el crecimiento económico que
ha sido positivo pero no ha sido el
mejor en la historia porque venía en
tendencia positiva desde desde
administraciones pasadas pero si la idea
de crear empleos del nacionalismo que
está promoviendo que yo considero que es
muy grave en mediano plazo pero que le
está funcionando para la atracción de
votos es el mensaje principal yo creo
que le está diciendo al pueblo americano
que con que de continuar con las
políticas económicas del partido
republicano se continuará generando
empleos para todos los rubros y se
continuará con una política de
crecimiento económico si bien yo tengo
hay un tema y él habló sobre el sector
manufacturero que se están creando
empleos y aquí ojo porque en un futuro
este tipo de empleos se van a robotizar
y todo estos empleos que se crearon se
habían perdido perdón en
administraciones pasadas tres veces más
se habían creado empresas empleos
tecnológicos en sillicon valley etcétera
entonces creo que es un mensaje muy
cortoplacista de largo plazo
evidence en pensar en empleos con valor
agregado tecnológico que son los que
realmente han empujado el crecimiento
potencial de la economía americana por
todos estos años entonces yo creo que es
una visión cortoplacista que le ha
funcionado a donald trump y veremos yo
creo que va a depender de la
recuperación económica qué tan rápido se
dé la economía americana las
posibilidades que tenga trump en
elegirse bueno pues vamos a hablar ahora
también con jeffrey quien abogado desde
washington sobre las palabras de mike
pence no las escuchamos completas pero
entendimos si la mayoría los mensajes
dirigidos a responder el mensaje de joe
biden en la convención demócrata a
resaltar los avances y avances respecto
al coi a mostrar también esos héroes que
estaban en primera fila los veteranos de
las diferentes fuerzas militares de eeuu
también los bomberos los médicos
usted este discurso en cuanto al
posicionamiento de la campaña
republicana en los meses que quedan de
aquí a noviembre
pero hay una diferencia entre la
convención demócrata en la convención
republicana la convención demócratas
solamente nos ha informado lo malo que
es lo malo que es eeuu y lo malo que es
la gente aquí no nos han acusado de
racistas nos han acusado de sexistas nos
han acusado de que hay no hay igualdad
entre clases sociales y un montón de
cosas más pero yo yo
el vicepresidente pensé ha hecho un
resumen de lo que se ha hecho no la
economía en estos últimos cuatro años ha
sido un completo éxito a nosotros los
hispanos nos está yendo muy muy bien con
el señor de trump con este gobierno y en
cuatro años más no nos va a ir muchísimo
mejor muchísimo mejor
lo mismo que a hispanoamérica porque
eeuu es el motor económico de apps de
toda la región empezando por méxico ahí
vamos bajando bajando no solamente por
el intercambio comercial sino por las
remesas que se envían de los eeuu por
los inmigrantes a sus países de origen
qué es
muchos de los casos o en todos los casos
es gran parte de la economía gran gran
parte de la economía lo que voy a
resaltar es el mensaje de unidad que el
vicepresidente pensé nos ha dado unidad
hay que pensar en el país hay que pensar
en los eeuu hay que rescatar el orgullo
de vivir en este país porque en realidad
es un buen país es un muy buen país es
el mejor país del mundo si es que tienes
alguna
color diferente al que no sea blanco
como dice es imposible no caer en el
racismo pero este es un buen país es el
mejor país del mundo y no hay que tener
vergüenza al decirlo en cambio los
demócratas tienen vergüenza en decir
este es el mejor país del mundo yo soy
inmigrante en los eeuu soy un ciudadano
americano y no tengo vergüenza no siento
vergüenza de decir eeuu es el mejor país
del mundo y lo podemos hacer muchísimo
mejor y lo vamos a hacer en estos 4 años
más que vamos a tener con el presidente
de donald trump en el gobierno de la
meta ahora es encontrar la paz
en todo el medio oriente que ya se
empezó a hacer peso pero vamos a
encontrar la paz sí bueno pues también
podemos analizar qué es uno de los pocos
actos presenciales que se ha visto
durante la convención republicana
usualmente es un evento masivo que reúne
a miles de personas pero que se ha
estado casi en su totalidad a lo virtual
sabíamos que habría eventos presenciales
como el que acabamos de ver aquí en la
intervención del vicepresidente mike
pence pero por supuesto que también
resaltar que la mayoría de la convención
feliz fue virtual a diferencia de la
republicana que en su totalidad fue
virtual la demócrata que fue virtual en
su totalidad pues por su postura frente
al coi 19 finalizamos entonces con jose
bastos y su opinión frente al discurso
de mike pence señor bastos estamos con
usted para que nos cuenten que darles a
usted por ejemplo el tema de empleos de
estos 9.3 vídeo de empleos de los que
habla mike pence ante la promesa que
habían hecho en su campaña 2016 de
generar 10 millones de empleos qué opina
usted del tema de la vacuna coi 19 que
plantea el vicepresidente precisó la
lista para finales de este año y como
estos también son caballos de batalla
publicaron para su nueva campaña la
presidencia
sí creo que en el tema económico va a
ser fundamental si realmente hay una
recuperación que estable de aquí al mes
de octubre mes de noviembre
recuperándose de lo que fueron los
cierres por el coronavirus creo que las
aspiraciones y la posibilidad de tron de
reelegirse será mucho mejor de momento
en la mayoría de los trabajos que se han
recuperado han sido muchos empleos que
las empresas habían cerrado
temporalmente y volvieron no nos
realmente una una creación de nuevos
empleos pero si la economía realmente
puede sostenerse y recuperarse de que
noviembre a pesar de la pandemia creo
que sin duda es el mensaje principal que
tiene que dar el partido republicano en
cuanto a la vacuna bueno
los expertos quizás difieren sobre
cuándo podría estar obviamente si hay
una vacuna aprobada antes de las
elecciones sería es clave para para la
reelección de trump no parece que los
tiempos van a dar y realmente es un
esfuerzo combinado de muchas muchas
agencias del gobierno muchas empresas
privadas no no no no no podría decirse
que solamente gracias a trompas pero
obviamente mientras mejor se controla la
pandemia mientras mejor se recupere la
economía
trump mejorará al día de hoy ninguna de
esas dos cosas está totalmente bajo
control y por eso vemos un yo vaivén
superando al trompo por cierta con
cierta ventaja en las encuestas pues los
invitamos a ustedes de miedo audiencia
france24 continuar con este especial
informativo mañana a las 20 horas de
bogotá quito lima ciudad ebéjico a
general 24 y por supuesto agradecemos la
presencia de esos invitados que nos haya
acompañado por dos horas y media ellos
son josé bastos desde washington también
jeffrey quien desde washington dc
también y también jesús garza desde
monterrey en méxico gracias a ustedes
puede ser parte de este análisis central
24 y a ustedes la audiencia que nos
acompaña también les agradecemos los
invitamos a continuar con más en nuestra
página web france24 punto con más
información y en cuatro idiomas para
ustedes este france24 nos vemos más
adelante